en el día número 18 de paro nacional en
colombia el epicentro de las protestas
se trasladó a bogotá la capital el
monumento a los héroes en el norte de la
ciudad fue el lugar de la masiva
congregación el descontento que estalló
por la reforma tributaria del gobierno
duque suman nuevos argumentos la
brutalidad de la fuerza pública
protagoniza la indignación entre las
denuncias de violencia las de violencia
sexual hoy salimos a las calles porque
estamos cansados de este autoritarismo
de este régimen que nos responde con
represión no nos escucha quienes se
reúnen con el gobierno tampoco nos
representan tenemos una agenda clara
desde las calles una reforma policial
que se tumbe el régimen y la reforma a
la salud y cómo responde el gobierno
violando a nuestras hermanas masacrando
nos y este es un claro ejemplo del
descontento social la presunta agresión
sexual de la menor de edad
allison meléndez por parte de cuatro
uniformados que llevó a la adolescencia
a suicidarse encendió el viernes las
calles de popayán donde murió un joven
supuestamente por el impacto de una
granada aturdidora de la policía en el
cuello
la misma noche fue incendiado el
edificio de medicina legal incidente que
el gobierno en marco en su narrativa de
que las guerrillas están detrás de las
protestas los cuatro agentes implicados
en la detención de meléndez fueron
apartados temporalmente del cuerpo según
la policía además el fiscal general
anunció la investigación del caso
la ong temblores registra al menos 16
casos de violencia sexual desde el
inicio de las protestas el 28 de abril
lo que piden muchos de los manifestantes
ya no son medidas disciplinarias
puntuales sino una reforma profunda de
la fuerza pública un punto sobre la mesa
de negociación que se iniciará este
domingo entre gobierno y comité de paro